好 今天很酷啊 晚安 晚上好
今天是个很好东西 哈喽
哈喽 今天是什么东西呢
嗯 嗯 晚安好
嗯 晚安好 晚安 晚安好 该刮了
行 我们找个 我们找个时间把它刮了
晚上好啊 今天晚上还发点什么东西呢
嗯 一把多
这个好 那不是这个这个
嗯 嗯 嗯 嗯 嗯 嗯 嗯 嗯
不是,还要没有一个,这个版儿,这个版儿
不是,还应该有一个,把它打开
这个,这个
还有,好,各位大会见
年轻的时候的痛苦就是后悔
完,完,完,完,好,完,上,好
回你一下完,完,完,回你一下完
这还没开始,了吗?
还有,这什么,什么声音
老火机
今天,今天的老火机们应该多
我其实特别希望今天老火机们多
因为我今天有一个预感
我会有很多好玩的东西
应该是为那次吧,感谢哈倫
我如果今天我有预感
所以我是特别希望今天有很多老火机来
叫做什么呢?今天讲变成
今天讲变成
讲变成
我们今天讲变成
好吧,我好久没有讲过变
你们可能都不知道我曾经当过十年程序员
例不厉害吧
最近形式,最近有啥形式的形式
说了好多次了
因为,就是一起度
肯定是有,肯定是有一些财政的厉害
这个不用想,对吧
一记多,一二三
月份肯定是有厉害的
罗记已经说得很清楚了
因为留给我们的时间,就是时间窗口
你们知道了
所以不用担心不用遭击
我今天清了两个藏
我今天有两个清擦了
不是两个清擦,有两个
有两个标击到我给清掉了
我会减少我的标击的数量
然后卡在几个关键点上
未来我不会吃,我不会吃那么多的公司
我会吃一点点
我会吃几个公司
大概这个罗记呗,对吧
大概就是这么一个罗记
我要说哪两个我不是什么
要吃,吃点什么东西的吗?
感谢性命
你不让我吃老饭的吗?对不对
不要结果
咱们不会给结果的
包括之前我还跟大叔
可以这个,以后不会讲了
以后不会讲了
我们只是给大家做分析
就要说分析的方法之类的
就要分析的方法之类的
我们现在有人问我
那个什么样
我们不会打
因为该说罗记我都说过
然后你在问我,你干吗?
你想问啥呢?
对不对
我们罗记在那儿呢
早就说过了,罗记变了吗?
没变
对吧
你当初被说买的呢?
罗记没变
然后人家关键点你就做不住了
那我给你飞机拿
对不对
他赶跌
我就赶加
对不对
为什么他赶跌我就赶加
因为很清楚
我觉得很有信心
对吧
所以前一段时间
打跌的时候
我就大家
最近怎么了
那有些就不卖了
有些就清掉
对不对
怕什么呢?
因为我对这个东西非常的了解
我既然如此了解我怕什么呢?
所以
一切都在什么呢?
一切都是你对这个东西
到底有多了解
变啥了哪边呢?
哪边呢?
前两天有一个小伙伴似的好玩问我
说胡子哥
那个电梯的那个广告
那个龙头
我受不了了
都变成那个样子了
那我就怎么办
那我就大加了
加完以后呢?
加完以后就吃肉味
是不是
大部分说你现在
我只是说以前发生过的事情
因为我就做过的了解
因为我对他足够的了解
但是我想跟大家说
以前我看好的很多的公司
我最近做了一些
处理
做了些什么处理呢?
就是我觉得不在
对吧
我觉得不在
看
当初好的人认我
对吧
你说你要是很清楚
你要对一个东西努力
所以你看我当时
你看我当时加了一笔
我当时加了一笔
但是我分了三个买的
分了三个买的
你就想像我当时加多少
难得有个机会量
难得有机会
夸插插进去
然后30%
所以我说
我在跟大家分享什么
这个钱啊
你在证什么钱
你在证
认知以内的钱
就是如果你荒了
如果你荒了
说明什么
说明你对的公司不了解
是这样的吗
那么这个时候你就不要去担心
说我该下还是不该下
我该跑还是什么
这个时候你又考虑的
不是这个问题
当一个公司股价下跌的时候
然后你开始荒了
这个时候说明的第一个问题
其实我对这个公司不了解
你这时候应该复盘
是我为什么不了解
我干嘛去了
我正是什么钱
你应该是做这样的意见思考
而不是到处分
我是该加完这该跑
那你不是韭菜吗
对吧
那不是韭菜吗
所以我希望各位
我其实特别开心的是什么
因为我们有一些小口包的
有一些我们的小口包的
我们有一些群
我看到很多小白菜们留言
说一点都不荒
这我就很开心
为什么呢
因为你是了解我的亚公司的
对吧
那我们一长就开心的不了
一跌就荒的一比
那你这个钱就不该这么
是不是
以后我想想你们的邏輯
对不对
所以各位还是做得有意思的事情
所以我们未来我会花更多时间去
和大家分享一些思考
怎么就思考
我们考得这些东西
而且我希望明天跟大家说
其实我今天连得清了两家公司
我不是说的不看好了
我不是说我不看好的
这两家公司了
这两公司正常很好
但是我把他卖了的原因
是因为有更好的机会了
就更好的机会了
所以未来我会调查
我常调到少数的几个
不会吃了那么多了
所以我应该会把我的双微控制在5个之内
现在现在还有7个呢
所以我可能还要点
再剪到两到3个
这样
对
就是机会成本的问题吧
来过各位
我们来和大家分享一下
分享一下
今天要讲的东西
所以我跟大家分享
我最近我的状态特别好
咱们不想
咱们和大家分享的是算法
我们现在现在我们不太考虑
不太给他讲投资
过上一个人真正投资吧
但我在讲投资的时候的话
是以现在为基础的
这个基础是什么
这个基础就是
我们怎么能提升我们的人生算法
所以后面我们在这个大家分析的时候
也是讲过的算法是什么
不是说不是不会给结果的
这样的话就会有一个缺陷
什么缺陷呢
就是没流量
就是你会发现如果你是讲一些
让大家去提升任职的东西
它是没有流量的
但小小才行的流量的话
不要紧
咱就没有流量了
我现在很任性
自从粉丝过了三百之后
我特别任性
特别任性
叫做粉丝干嘛呢
对吧
有一些老火级又好
所以我们关注的小老火级
要以玩的心态来到这个时间
来
我那个啥了
我那个路隐了
因为我预感今天晚上
可能会有一些好玩的东西
来吧开始吧
开始吧
首先和大家分享一下
状态程序编程
然后我给大家讲一个编程
最简单的东西
然后这样啊
这个酒书酸酸
所以我也已经好久没有
没有好久一段时间
没写这个代码了
所以我还可以找本书
所以不推荐你买这本书
不推荐
我只是拿过来
和大家分享几个好玩的东西
这个好酷的
为什么
因为最近我突然又明白了
一个很有意思的东西
你下次你明白了
我想跟大家讲第一个概念
一个很重要的概念
一个非常重要的概念
叫做喊书
来
我们来讲编程啊
我们讲人生算法
来来我把这个屏幕剪在这里
要不然很多人以为我真的在讲编程
来我们讲人生算的
这是我们讲这一东西
给你的人生编程
那么讲人生算法
你不用想啊
你说不会编程不重要
各位
你说我不会编程不重要
我只是跟讲一些最基本的支持
如果没跟你讲明白
拿书眠水平赖
不是你不是你的基础差
可以的吧
可以的啊
来
如果如果讲完了以后
你没明白
书眠过讲的赖
但不是你的基础差
来我们讲第一个关键概念
叫喊书
我先跟大家讲第一个关键概念
还书
这就可以了
这会不法了吧
人生算法
这就这样
OK的吧
我们讲第一个喊书
喊书
喊书是编程里边
一个最基本的技能
那么这个喊书是干嘛呢
我来跟你解释一下
这个喊书可以有意思
我先跟一些写个最基础的
最基础的写法
什么的喊书呢
比如说
Joss Queen的里边是没有一个
喊书这么写的
哇
就是我身边一个喊书
喊书的一个喊书什么呢
夾法
让女方神
这就是喊书
你先不用考虑
你不用会写程序
我只是为你讲一个东西
我是在用编程来引预
而且这个对你的帮助特别大
然后呢
这里有两个变量
一个是A
一个是B
然后这个时候呢
我写了一个很小的程序
主意识
A加B
好了
可以了
就这么简单
我们今天就想在一个喊书
然后我先来解释一个问题
看不懂不重要
那等一下
我给你骑啊
那你看什么不懂
我不需要你会变成
明白吗
我得给你骑啊
我觉得好多人这个脑的
你受目马了
什么脑马
上来第一件事是我不懂